okay newer 15-minute game started I
played f1 d4 already so let's let's okay
well maybe he wants to what's it what's
this I think he thinks it's a bullet
game or something
what okay just gifted me a pawn so for
not much I think it's it's a little bit
of reverse term Smith Morrill gambit you
can just develop normally and have extra
pawn for nothing
think
yeah what can choose various setups of
course g3 or or with III whatever it's
just it just an extra pond well even in
this myth Mariah it's very questionable
if white has got great compensation he's
got some compensation of course but it's
hard to believe that it would be to an
advantage and with just one tempo down
it's just a part for nothing
f5 this is weird when the normal
reaction would be to take on e5 simply
to to get the d4 fork going but okay
maybe maybe that's even something better
we should be v also looks like an
attractive option if he once should be
five just to text me five and if he
pushes forward I have 95 threatenings on
c6 and threatening Queen h5 it's
certainly good for white 95 is also good
okay let's let's try this one if he
tries to to cover you five with I don't
know okay pretty far already
okay well let's just just quickly check
alternatives because this is really hard
to believe that black should survive
this kind of opening play let's say 95
we can they can play Queen d6 Mary
cover cover c6 and prepare g6 in
response to Queen h5 but I could always
play Knight to c4 then with the tempo he
could go Queen f6 but then half g4 as
well yeah let's go 95
I was also thinking briefly about not to
deform not to divorce also not without
its points but not if I should just be a
strong move 95 got the idea if he takes
on d4 with the bishop 84 I'm threatening
d5 so I guess he must take on d4 with
the Queen and then I would just castle
and play d3 Bishop e3 and get all my
pieces out with tempo would have the
huge advantage development and also this
pawn moves to e4 and f5 just weakened
blacks position so but this should be
should be fine
Queen f6 I'll have enough default so
yeah okay now I have a very nice choice
I can play d4 I can play f4 I can play
Knight to c4 and game gains tempo yeah
maybe just deformed
this just intends to to take the c5
bishop
yeah he just ignored it was more
expecting that he would retreat to b6 or
something
what I'd like to do is to prevent him
from castling yeah okay just just grab
this phone
maybe Queen b3 in order to uh to UM
indent from counseling
hmm
yeah
I'd like to do is just a short castle
any form to open the position I'm really
up okay this doesn't do much maybe once
no Kassebaum mmm okay yeah he for looks
just like a normal move to to open the
position really really up here yeah
that's let's just go for this
this must be okay don't want to play any
snow moves here and just okay I've got
an extra pawn and I could have played I
don't know Bishop d2 or something but it
looks looks better to get to see one
Bishop involved here - 2 e 3 or 4 after
all his King is not really is that safe
ok now Bishop to a4 or Bishop to e3
hmm
you know maybe to a form I'd like to
this is of course a nice position of the
bishop and that it gives various nice
attacking ideas this kind of position
with the bishop on f4 and the King on c8
always gives nice ideas in terms of
meeting the king really let's imagine
that b7 point is not there then Bishop
a6 would be just made our imagine let's
say I would play queen a for I place a
six I can just take on Essex with the
Queen even and be a six Bishop a six
would be made so these two bishops can
deliver mate and another mate here would
be a knight on b6 let's say you would
play a six in this position I could play
94 between b5 Queen takes b5 maybe 596
checkmate so this Bishop position might
give me some some nicer Taking Chances
yeah this was another idea of course and
now let's check if I've got some some
tricks here based on the mentioned that
active position of the of the bishop
I can always take on dissent of course
don't find anything better but maybe
there are some something more attractive
even what kinds of mates are
let's quickly check when a form let say
Knight takes Knight takes I can take
with the bishop okay this is no idea
okay that's nothing so spectacular so I
need to take care so what now just queen
a forum with the idea to play Roxy one
next
we had leadership on that for us really
an annoying piece and the setup with the
rook on the Queen on c5 and the King on
c8 this is uncomfortable really
the only problem of course is the nicely
placed night on the forum so let's say I
go for a no Roxy one at some point and
try to move the knight on c3 where you
would have 90 to check always
how to suggest the defensive move if he
plays Quincy six I can take a seven and
seven is also always hanging I can play
B five when I have Queen a six a six
check simply night II 6 I just drop back
to you 3 not sure don't see you don't
see a really really great move
yep if he obviously doesn't see her some
good move as well boys searching for the
computer
yeah well let's wait what taught is
coming up with yes you had a long long
pause and posting videos because I
really got addicted to this this
computer game I'm playing a low Scrolls
five Skyrim really and it's it's
terribly addictive game and I'm also the
kind of person that likes to really get
the most out of his character at such
role-playing games like getting all
kinds of skills to maximum and
experimenting with different I don't
know
setups and strategies what kind of
skills you you should get for your
character and so on and yeah it takes
takes out of time but it's very very
much fun to fun to play and yeah I
already played a couple of years ago I
played the game that was the other with
the part for serious called oblivion and
I'd played this really excessively as
well for four weeks so when I bought
this game beginning of November I was
pretty much aware that it would take a
lot of time but I'm almost through this
I think so it's to be expected that I
would do more regularly videos again but
sure as he disconnected or something
that's really a long thing try quickly
to ping him know it seems to be
connected I seem to be connected as well
so it's really a long thing
yeah well you should at some point just
play a move but I know the problem I
have open I'm also always a candidate in
this kind of rapid endless games to
spend more time than I should
yeah well I don't have her a great
suggestion for black of course
maybe something like B 6 B 6 and then
King B 7 but I okay finally came up with
the move so now I'm Bishop d3 would be
it would be the normal way to play this
keep this on the great diagonal quasi
could play h5 yeah then the question is
what about rook c1 yeah
it's 92 business is really somewhat
annoying I could also go to e3 here it
would be perfectly fine yeah but this
bishop really belongs on this diagonal
I'm not only three okay let's go for
through the gut instinct here that this
Bishop should be here not only three of
course if one should calculate but I
don't want to spend so much time okay
let's let's say he plays h5 and just
consider this move well Roxy 192 is
really annoying so we'll see one doesn't
get so much do I have something else
doesn't pledge 5:40 should really you
try to get something going there
yeah it's hard to get a look on the sea
Farm is there some way to exchange the
night
aha
I was just thinking about what night be
five here not be five if it takes with a
knight on d5 Roxy one was just I doesn't
win a doll it did wins the Queen Edwin's
Aquino
we take to the Queen rb5 of God also
Luke c1 check it also should win yeah
lots of material so he cannot take this
but he can play 92 check King h19 takes
g3 check and then maybe F takes G
then f6 would be hanging and also Roxie
one would be threatened
and the only issues of the back rank of
course let's say we should be fine I'd
be 592 checking edge one night XG 3
check FG I'm very weak on the back rank
so sure well ok D 1 is coming outs away
by the Queen on a form
hmm okay let's Ted saying this position
the knight on f6 is hanging of course is
also wide table death porn
so if he moves the knight that say to g4
and then I play whoopsy one yeah yeah
fall here he'll have all kinds of tricks
then not f2 for instance not f2 was
working terrible yeah it's still
trickier
hmm but this is an interesting idea does
not b5 stuff
maybe I should we should do some
preparation right now of course we might
be 592 King Ashwin IG 3fg and Knight to
g4 to say that it looks completely silly
actually but maybe it is working on Rupe
c1 he's got not have to check simply
amazing
well maybe maybe just h3 let's play h3
here this reckons not b5 as on Knight to
e2 check I can just go to I can just go
to h2 hopefully or maybe maybe h1 is
this better
but this prepares I think might be 5 in
some way
yeah maybe rocky ain't wasn't such such
a bad bad idea
yes still a very tricky position let's
say for instance I plane I'd be five at
some point he plays ninety to check King
edge to and then I've this is this night
on e to is also very nicely placed for
various kinds of mates
just imagine he would have a look on the
sixth ranked him and he could play in
this position ninety five ninety to
check King edge to Nazi for Czech ATG
for rook h6 checkmate this is also
typical made with this night on e to or
his heaven and then made on with the
rubic second in the age file so I have
to really really be careful him my king
is of course safer than his King but
still a very tricky yeah we are almost
spending of the time II and the first 20
moves he's down to 130 and I really
should speed up now but I'm not the one
to accuse someone or something
I'm also terribly slow at times
well now he should move I'm two minutes
ahead of the clock this is unbelievable
and really happening very rally
hmm down to 40 seconds okay
okay let's say I just take this what's
what's the big big idea night at 5:00
maybe but not at 5:00 I can just take
and take a seven this should be you
should be enough okay but but this just
hangs there six right
there's no no big big trick or something
between a three I can just go to h2 no
I'm threatening whoopsy six with
checkmate to come yeah I can take No
okay so now I Ruth every move wins but
it says direct checkmate
don't think that I don't laugh okay
there is this may be a direct mate but I
don't I don't see it
Brooksie seventh king is six nights twin
to see four maybe this could be a maid
yeah okay Queen f7 oestrogen checkmate
yeah this was a interesting technical
technical position here that's a check
quickly yeah yeah okay account gives a
blue plus five yeah he wants to play a
c1 yeah it is this somehow it's
illogical man
yeah the computer is completely unfazed
by the prospect of 92 and Quincy one
computer line goes through Gracie one
rupee eight and then before a queen to
see 695 and wins
yeah I see this I see that this wins but
it wasn't to to clear for me during the
game well this of course keeps a large
advantage but ok the other movements of
course was much more forcing and this
loses our idea but it's it's a terrible
terrible difficult position to play for
black and in a limited time game
computer one supplier rupee 8 and that
King dat had this idea crossed my mind
in the game as well to try to evacuate
the King on foot so to say alright some
it's um it's difficult here but I'd like
to know is what the computer wants to
play in this position ok doesn't want to
play you forth it's it's also it's a
very human move it's not not much of a
computer move too but it ok it gives 1.5
doesn't see any any refutation or
something this is very much the main
line here it wants to play King dat ya
King the 8 was an idea that occurred to
me it's very difficult for black kids
also plus to the computers evaluation
here so I guess it was a good idea to
get with e4 to get this Bishop going and
not try to do some slow
the extra porn it's maybe technically
also a sound but this is just yeah the
right way to play chess try to play
active moves yeah okay thanks for
watching
I guess I'll do one more and then call
it quits for today